[MUSIC PLAYING]
MATT GAUNT: Um, so, yeah,
what happened at JQuery UK?
ADDY OSMANI: Nothing, nothing.
It was all flawless, and
I didn't get kicked off
stage in any way.
MATT GAUNT: I
heard the opposite.
ADDY OSMANI: That's hearsay.
MATT GAUNT: What sort of things
did you cover on you talk?
What was the talk about?
ADDY OSMANI: I can show you--
MATT GAUNT: Do it.
ADDY OSMANI: --some of the
stuff that was in the talk.
MATT GAUNT: What is in
the world of DevTools?
ADDY OSMANI: So much stuff.
All right.
So the first thing that I talked
about, well, one of the things
I talked about was a new
Eye Dropper, new plan
in the DevTools.
So instead of just being
able to select a color,
you can actually get this
nice magnifying glass
that lets you select any image
or any artifact in the page
and just grab a color from
it and start using it.
MATT GAUNT: Nice.
ADDY OSMANI: Which
is kind of useful,
so you don't need to go and use
an external tool to get that.
It's just straight in
the Elements panel.
MATT GAUNT: And then if
you've Workspaces set up,
it'll save it
straight to your CSS.
ADDY OSMANI: Exactly.
Oh, you use Workspaces.
You're already on top
of all that stuff.
MATT GAUNT: I'm aware of it.
ADDY OSMANI: You're aware of it.
OK.
[MUSIC PLAYING]